[Musique]
donc atteint
sarajevo entre calme et guerre
fantasmagorique on ne peut pas imaginer
qu'à demain quelqu'un va bombarder aux
couleurs à des soldats qui restent sur
un an
c'est la loi de la guerre telle que la
conçoivent les serbes
c'était un scandale c'était un siège
quasi médiévale des gens qui meurent
tous à 1h30 de vol de paris race est à
genoux sur le macadam en plein coeur de
sarajevo
c'est ça tire ça tu n'as tu pas passé q
passeport
alors on a appris à courir pour éviter
les balles
parfois long march confiant mais les
fous les ennemis de la paix sur sniper
avenues sont là pour rappeler un peuple
qu'il n'est pas le plus fort avec ses
faux espoirs
en lin penser qu'on va arrêter tout ça
créée en 1945 la république fédérative
populaire de yougoslavie est unis par la
volonté d'un seul homme le général tito
à sa mort en 1980 les nationalistes se
réveille la chute de l'urss accélèrent
leur prise de pouvoir dès 1991 la
slovénie puis la croatie d'écart leur
indépendance c'est quand même un château
de cartes qui commence à
la yougoslavie se disloque en seulement
quelques mois sous le regard incrédule
de la population on a déjà senti depuis
l'éviction de manif pour la paix tout ça
que ça va pas déjà avec slovénie croatie
mais on n'a jamais pensé que ça va venir
ça va au met doucement doucement
le 6 avril 1992 une manifestation
réunissant des milliers de personnes se
tient à sarajevo croates bosniaques
serbes
tous réclament la paix
j'avais dès 10h 10m des cartes y amener
les gens de tous les coins de bosnie
on organise un grand va nice pour la
paix le résultat des premières victimes
depuis le toit de l'holiday inn
dé nationaliste serbe ouvre le feu sur
la foule c'était panique absolue gens
qui sont connus dans tous les sens s'il
a eu des blessés l'un de ses
c'était beau de bordeaux
qui quitte après les premières
bombardements donc là là ça commence à
tirer dans tous les sens
c'était pas seulement
bombardés et tué les gens c'était pour
ces gens là c'était plaisir de détruire
une civilisation
les serbes installé depuis des mois sur
les collines surplombant la ville
pilonne sans relâche sarajevo le siège
de sarajevo c'est une cuvette à sarajevo
c'est ça fait à peu près 6000 mètres en
longueur et 2000 mètres en largeur il ya
vous avez 250 mille deux cent
quatre-vingt mille je crois que j'ai le
souvenir de 280 mille personnes là
dedans qui sont assiégés
la ville était défendu les puits les
serments jamais véritablement essayer de
prendre ou de rentrer et de faire mal
voilà c'est ça bombarde s attirer et
s'était essayé de mettre une certaine
pression sur les bosniaques pour que ils
finissent par se rendre passé le premier
était la situation se fige les
bombardements cessent parce c'est pas
quotidien il ya des périodes même de
cessez le feu qui sont plus ou moins
respecté ça finit toujours par fauré
rapidement la ville assiégée des coupés
du monde extérieur on nous coupe d'abord
le téléphone
grave après on nous coupait
l'électricité
on a même après comme envers les blues
il n'y a plus d'eau on a appris comment
tout faire avec 5 litre d'eau
tous les arbres qui avaient aux villes
ont terminé en bois de chauffage mais
aussi tous les bouquins scolaire tout ça
est parti partie en bois de chauffage
parce que les hivers peuvent être
peuvent être assez rude dès juillet 1992
un pont aérien est mise en place par
l'onu pour apporter une aide humanitaire
régulièrement pris pour cible par les
serbes
ils paieront eux aussi un lourd tribut
200 casques bleus seront tués en actu
gosses la vie dont 84 soldats français
sous bannière de l'oin
trois ans écoule rythmée par les
bombardements et les tirs de snipers
chaque sortie peut être synonyme de mort
mais il faudra attendre le bombardement
du 5 février
1994 sur le marché de markale et pour
que l'horreur de la situation devienne
intenable pour la communauté
internationale soixante-huit morts des
centaines de blessés
je suis sur place quelques minutes plus
tard et c'était
dans ce cas vraiment un carnage une
boucherie surtout quand c'est des femmes
des enfants enfin je leur cède pas mais
c'est pas des morts au combat quoi c'est
de l'assassinât pur et simple
essai du crime de guerre mais c'est
autrement
souvent cher l'ehpad claque ça s'est
passé comme ça que c'était un bon ou
mauvais ou quelque chose comme ça et ça
c'est la réalité
doit vivre avec ça si la pression
internationale s'accentue sur les serbes
cela ne suffit pas pour autant faire
lever le siège il faudra encore un an le
massacre de sebrenica à l'été 95 et les
accusations de nettoyage ethnique des
serbes sur les musulmans pour que les
casques bleus reçoivent enfin l'ordre de
libérer sarajevo par la force et cette
fois cette fois on est prêts à taper et
et on tape on finit par taper il ya une
campagne de bombardements qui durera
10 jours
l'arrêté sac garni jour le 29 février
1996 après trois ans huit mois et 9
jours le siège de sarajevo est enfin
levé laissant derrière lui des ruines
des tombes et beaucoup de larmes
[Musique]